[Music]
on this wednesday night how
vaccines will roll out one potential
vaccine moves a step closer to approval
what's canada's inoculation plan we
expect to receive
4 million doses between january and
march of the pfizer vaccine 2 million
for moderna
a nightmare situation in the north covit
19 spreads through communities in
nunavut
we didn't know they would rise once the
virus was in the territory
the challenge of containing the virus
and treating patients in such remote
places
plus do-it-yourself and at-home covid19
test
approved for use in the u.s if everyone
could spit on a piece of paper
every day and check themselves for
coving we would catch cases
how reliable are they and will they be
available in canada
and learning about long-term immunity
the data are very promising
but we should be still taking
precautions evidence immunity to the
coronavirus might last
months or possibly years
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is lots to get to tonight but we
begin on a rare positive note
it's about a possible vaccine for
covid19 pfizer and biontech say their
final analysis of the vaccine they've
been testing
shows it is more effective than expected
the phase 3 clinical trial involving
nearly 44 000 people is now complete
and the companies say the data shows it
is 95
effective up from 90 percent the
preliminary data showed last week
and in people over the age of 65 the
vaccine is 94
effective the companies say there were
no serious side effects
the results still need to be
independently analyzed
but pfizer says it plans to apply for
emergency
u.s authorization within days
canada has pre-ordered millions of doses
of the pfizer vaccine
it is being reviewed by health canada
through an expedited process
if all goes smoothly the first shipments
could arrive in the first few months of
2021
but there are lots of steps along the
way and even if it gets approved not
everyone will get it right away in our
top story tonight mike trolley looks at
the plans for vaccine rollout in canada
vaccine anticipation hit a fevered pitch
in recent weeks
are they effective and if so when would
we see them
well today canadians were given the most
definitive date yet
to circle on their calendars the doses
for canada we expect to receive
4 million doses between january and
march of the pfizer vaccine 2 million
for moderna
so that's two different vaccines with
possibly more becoming available
soon which epidemiologists say is
important because not every vaccine
works well for everyone
and the pfizer product in particular has
its limitations
a significant fly in the ointment with
the pfizer vaccine
is it needs to be stored at incredibly
cold temperatures
and you know very few places have the
facilities for such a deep freeze
so there's a lot of obstacles that
really have to be surmounted with this
the obvious issue is a limited number of
doses available right away
so a tentative rollout plan would look
something like this
canadians at high risk be it elderly or
those with high-risk conditions
would get it first followed by
front-line workers which includes
workers in healthcare and long-term care
facilities
as well as people living with high-risk
individuals the third group would be
workers essential to society such as
police
firefighters and grocery store staff
fourth
high-risk zones like indigenous
communities with two autoimmune diseases
georgina monteith qualifies for the
first group
but says she'll decline she lost both
her legs to diabetes
and with a compromised immune system she
doesn't trust any new medication in her
system
i don't want to have any kind of a
adverse reaction to the vaccine where my
body itself
starts thinking this is something it
needs to attack or
the vaccine does the reverse and attacks
something in my own
system initial reports show the vaccine
is effective with
few side effects so as much as the
disbursement has to be fair
the government also has to communicate
how safe it is
and realistically even with the vaccine
we won't get rid of covet 19 overnight
we're going to have to wear mass and
keep our distance and limit gatherings
and stuff
well into next fall probably you know
because it's going to take a while
to get immunogenic saturation in the
population to reach herd immunity
mike drolit global news toronto here are
the latest numbers on how covet 19 is
spreading right now
they paint a worrying picture in the
last day in ontario more than 1400
people tested positive
and 32 people died in the rest of the
country manitoba reported 400 new cases
today
and 11 more deaths that is a record high
bc broke yet another daily record today
more than 760 new cases
and in nunavut 10 more people tested
positive
this is what the map looks like adjusted
for population manitoba still has the
most
active cases per capita 519 cases
per 100 000 people and none of it which
two weeks ago had no cases is now a hot
spot the fourth
hardest hit region per capita in canada
there are now 70 active cases in nunavut
the entire territory is under tight
restrictions
for the next two weeks eric sorenson on
the risks of the coronavirus spreading
in canada's most remote communities
for months isolation was a great defense
against covid19
but once the virus slipped into canada's
largest territory isolation became a
disadvantage
the worst outbreak is in arviat a
community of more than 2600
like much of nunavut arvied is
accessible only by air or snowmobile
often with large families living in
small houses and with limited healthcare
resources
much of the outbreak is along western
hudson bay arviet has diagnosed eight
new covet 19 cases and now has
54. whale cove has eight cases
the largest community in the area rankin
inlet now has six
and santa kilawack has two so far 70 in
a matter of days
this is it folks it's time to take a
stand and fight against covet 19.
we need you all to make sacrifices now
to protect our communities that
sacrifice means a two-week lockdown for
all communities in nunavut except for
essential workers and essential needs
the people are being told to stay home
not socialize not travel premier joe
savikatak told global news they can
handle four communities but not much
more
if it gets any more than that and our
resources would be uh
would be beyond we need more resources
right now we are
pretty well at the limit of our
resources in dealing with uh four
communities
most communities in the north have at
most a health center such as this in
rankin inlet
the seriously ill would have to be flown
out if anybody is in
that situation where they need ongoing
fluid
oxygen or life support then
they obviously can't stay in a health
center and will need to go to a southern
hospital
ottawa has helped with more testing
capacity it's also prepared to move
covet patients from their homes if the
virus keeps spreading
that involves repurposing schools in
some cases repurposing
community centers to make sure there's a
there's there's isolation
and testing capacity and it's something
that we're very very worried about
particularly since you have people of
many generations living under one roof
if necessary the military can and would
be sent north
it's hoped it won't come to that what
we're watching for right now
is the numbers if we can get the numbers
to
be low or stay stagnant then we know
there's no community spread
the next two weeks will be nervous ones
as nunavut waits to see if the lockdown
can curb the outbreak eric sorensen
global news toronto
global news has confirmed the u.s canada
border will remain closed to all
non-essential travel
until at least december 21st and today
bc's premier said people
shouldn't be traveling in or out of
british columbia
unless it's essential
we need a pan-canadian approach to
travel we need to make sure that people
in coquitlam are living under the same
rules as people in chicoutimi
we need to make sure that those who want
to come to british columbia must only do
so if it is essential
for their business or their well-being
it's not an order
it's an ask premier horgan says he plans
to call on the prime minister and other
premiers to actively discourage people
from traveling
outside their home province the u.s food
and drug administration has issued
emergency use authorization for the
first
covid19 test kit that can be used at
home
a prescription is needed for it it uses
a nasal swab and gives results in 30
minutes
and it could be used in emergency rooms
and doctors offices too
it's not approved for use in canada
though there has been talk of a home
test
for months now david aiken looks at
where things stand
testing testing and more testing it
is the key to controlling community
spread of covet 19.
that's because most of the community
spread in canada right now involves
people
who have no symptoms and unaware of
their condition
continue going about their daily routine
and infecting
others some say a rapid home
test kit would help prevent those
asymptomatic
kovid 19 carriers from spreading it
around because they know
to stay home and self-isolate we could
open up businesses
if everyone could spit on a piece of
paper every day
and check themselves for coving we would
catch cases we wouldn't catch all them
but we would catch enough that we could
open up we could do that
but that actually would require federal
leadership health canada has approved a
handful of
rapid test kits but those can only be
used by health care professionals
health canada has neither approved nor
is currently evaluating
any rapid home test kits meanwhile
the united states food and drug
administration this week announced it
had approved
yet another home test kit canada has
asked that manufacturer and others
to consider submitting their kits to
canadian regulators
at the end of the day you know you can't
rush science and i would just say that
if there are promising manufacturers out
there that have not submitted to canada
they certainly should
and we will take a look at them very
quickly if those test makers do submit
their products to health canada
experts hope approval is in fact speedy
the tests
are getting better and they're over time
the
false positivity rate is declining
canada is now testing about
58 000 people a day but experts say
200 000 a day need to be tested
and rapid tests including rapid home
tests
will be critical in meeting that testing
capacity david aiken global news
ottawa ontario's education minister says
the province's schools are staying open
and will not have an extended christmas
break
earlier this week steven leche said
adding two weeks onto the christmas
break was being considered
today he said it's not warranted because
according to him schools have been
remarkably
successful at minimizing outbreaks
the safest place with the cohorts
are in schools and so far it's i'm going
to knock on what it's
it's working over 99 percent of the kids
are coveted free and that's the same
with
with staff so that's the safest place
in new york city though public schools
are closing tomorrow
more than one million students in the
nation's largest school district will
move back to remote learning
new york has reached a 3 percent test
positivity rate though
transmission levels within schools are
low and many parents are now scrambling
to cope with having kids at home
across the u.s covet 19 case numbers are
at record levels
more than 136 000 new cases were
reported today
and more than 1500 people died and the
u.s hit a new milestone today
250 000 people have now died of covid19
since the start
of the pandemic as case numbers and
deaths soar president donald trump is
still refusing to accept the election
results
and refusing to cooperate in a
transition to president-elect joe biden
instead trump fired the top official in
charge of election security
and he seems intent on spending his
final days in office
ridding the administration of officials
he sees as
insufficiently loyal jackson proskow
reports in an unprecedented move
this is a disgrace the board of
elections in wayne county michigan
initially refused to certify its
election results
shame on you shame on you
for leading to this level of corruption
you have disavowed
your right to even sit in the seats that
you occupy
two republican members tried to block
the process claiming widespread
irregularities
that echoed president donald trump's
baseless claims
in the end they relented but soon after
trump's effort to discredit the vote
claimed a new victim be prepared for
efforts that call into question the
legitimacy of the election
that's christopher krebs who oversaw the
agency tasked with election security
he was fired by trump late tuesday after
openly debunking every one of the
president's lies about widespread voter
fraud
there is no evidence that any voting
system deleted or lost votes
changed votes or was in any way
compromised read one statement issued by
krebs agency
trump is just moving any person out of
the way that has any kind of
institutional power
to check him well that's the president's
right to do it
still republicans are standing by their
man refusing to acknowledge joe biden as
president-elect
i don't think we're going to have an
interrupted
transition to whoever is the next
administration but the transition is
being delayed by trump's intransigence
biden's team says it can't access
critical data about the response to the
covit 19 pandemic
like plans to distribute a vaccine which
unless it's made available soon we're
going to be behind
by weeks or months being able to put
together the whole
initiative and as the pandemic rages
unchecked in this country the current
president is facing pressure to deal
with reality
members of the white house coronavirus
task force have reportedly told the
president
he needs to change course to avoid a
catastrophic daily death toll
donna all right jackson proskow in
washington thanks
in berlin germany police in riot gear
broke up a big demonstration of people
angry about the government's plan to
enshrine cobit 19 restrictions
in law
police used water cannon to disperse a
crowd of thousands of people near
berlin's landmark brandenburg gate
they moved in after demonstrators
ignored calls to wear masks and keep
their distance
protesters threw flares and set off
smoke bombs at least 200 people were
detained
german lawmakers are debating a bill
that would strengthen government powers
to impose further pandemic restrictions
critics say the law would endanger
citizens civil rights
germany has almost 300 000 active
covid19 cases and more than
13 000 people have died
leading the way coming up vancouver's
plan to decriminalize simple possession
of hard drugs
plus back in the sky the news boeing
was waiting for
the overdose crisis in this country has
not gone away
during the pandemic in fact it is
getting worse tonight vancouver's mayor
is calling for a new approach
kennedy stewart wants to decriminalize
the simple possession of hard drugs in
his city
if approved by the federal government it
will be a first for canada
global's jordan armstrong is in
vancouver
jordan donna saying drug use isn't a
criminal issue but a health one
vancouver's mayor is calling for a new
approach
kennedy stewart says there have been
more than 1500 overdose deaths in
vancouver
since april 2016 when a public health
emergency was declared in bc
and he wants the federal government to
decriminalize the simple possession of
illicit drugs
if vancouver council backs him the mayor
says he'll write a letter to federal
officials
requesting an exemption to the
controlled drugs and substances act
an exemption that would end at
vancouver's boundaries
this is one tool and a series of tools
for example safe supply is also a
critical
component of reducing overdoses in
overdose deaths but what's so important
about decriminalization is it starts to
stop the stigma reduce the stigma around
drug use
and that means people are more likely to
to
access essential health services kennedy
stewart isn't alone bc's premier
supports the idea
as does the canadian association of
chiefs of police the head of that
association is vancouver police chief
adam palmer
but of course it isn't up to them ottawa
must be convinced
and as recently as september the prime
minister rejected calls to decriminalize
possession
saying the idea is not a silver bullet
donna
okay jordan armstrong in vancouver
tonight thanks
still ahead when boeing 737 max jets
will fly again
in canada
the u.s has cleared boeing's 737 max
jets for takeoff but at this point
canada is not following suit
the u.s federal aviation administration
says airlines in the u.s will be able to
fly the max series after boeing
updates critical software on each plane
and pilots receive training
canadian restrictions remain in place
while transport canada finishes its own
investigation
in a statement the transport minister
says canada will impose different
requirements for operators including
additional flight deck and pre-flight
procedures as well as different training
the 737 max jets have been grounded
since march of 2019
after two deadly crashes killed more
than 340 people
including 18 canadians
next the study raising hopes about
covid19 immunity
you're watching global national
it can be hard to find hopeful news
these days but there is a potential
bright spot tonight it's a study about
immunity the most comprehensive and
long-ranging study of immune
memory to the coronavirus it hasn't been
peer reviewed or published in a
scientific journal so it needs scrutiny
but it found most patients who recover
from the virus still have good immunity
six months later
and possibly longer heather urix west
explains what we know
and don't know luanne carl was on a
camping trip with her husband last
summer
when she became ill with covid19 my
husband
russ who was also positive but had a
mild case
he had to help me walk he had to wash my
hair
i just couldn't i couldn't even sit up i
was that weak
carl says the experience was frightening
and one she never wants to repeat
new data suggests at least in the short
term she likely won't have to
this is a really good news story it
tells us that the immune response
is behaving as exactly as our textbooks
tell
us that it should researchers from the
la jolla institute of immunology
collected blood samples from 185 people
who had recovered from mostly mild cases
of covid19
they then tracked four components of the
person's immune response
antibodies two types of t cells and b
cells
at the end of six months they found most
patients still had strong immunity
against reinfection this is important
to take us forward to better understand
the long-term
immune response to sarge kov2 or the
coca-19 virus
but not definitive at this stage that's
because not every person's immune system
will react the same way
and so while reinfection may be unlikely
it's never
impossible and there's another big
question as well
how does the state of immunity in uri
if we've been infected with
sarge kov2 does that make us less likely
to transmit the virus if we come in
contact with it again
to somebody else that means you might be
immune and still have the ability to
make someone else sick
it's why even with this hopeful news
carl isn't taking any chances
we just don't know and and to to be safe
is
is a really easy thing to do heather
urex west global news
calgary and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is this view of
lake erie from chatham-kent ontario
we'd love to see your part of this
beautiful country email your canada to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye